what you look like there the way you
look like well what this this was taken
on the set of which way to the front
where you allowed me to come and and
shadow you and watch you work I learned
a lot of stuff from from you on that set
that was after the class but I remember
one day you were shooting with the late
Steve Franken yes and you were doing a
scene where he was he was making a
peanut butter sandwich and you wanted
him to look nervous and so you told him
you were talking all to him all the way
through it say okay take the the knife
out of the peanut butter jar now put the
bread on the thing and you kept talking
really really fast to him and he was
trying to follow your your commands and
what it did was it made him look like he
was tremendously nervous and then they
took out your track in it and it worked
really well it was just a great
technique that I wouldn't have thought
of it was really really cool
well I told you when you were in the
class that you're gonna see great things
uh-huh well some of the other students
well when we heard that you were going
to come and teach we didn't know what to
expect we thought it would be like funny
stories and the stand-up routine kind of
like the Nutty Professor comes to USC
but we weren't prepared that for to
learn all about how to work with actors
and do the technical stuff and put it
together in the total filmmaker and your
book which I still have the original
book this is worth a thousand dollars on
eBay I looked it up today I've been
buying I selling them for months
so some of the other students that came
through your class were George Lucas and
we brought Steve Spielberg in to show am
Peter Bogdanovich field burger when when
we were at USC all our professor it was
before any of this those students had
ever gone into the industry and become
directors and all of our professors told
us that we couldn't make it to make that
transition they said we'd have to work
as you know in educational films or
industrial films that nobody who did not
have contacts or was related to someone
could get into the movie business but
you were the only professor who didn't
ignore that and just said you know go
for it and and we all did and and it
worked well those people that deny you
the thrill of knowing you could go
forward those are people that really
didn't look closely enough and they just
got in a way of their schedules and
that's some of the unkind stuff that
happens and when I know what's happening
I got to protect the kid you know yeah
yeah well some of the things that you I
still remember that you taught us was
when you're looking setting up a shot
think about the setup before and the
setup after in terms of the editing so
that you can even in your mind figure
out where the framing is and what's
going to be on the shot next and
afterwards how many directors make a
shot for their film and they really
didn't think it out and that shot gets
in the way of the rhythm and the pace of
the whole film so it has to go away well
you were telling us at lunch that that
Charlie Chaplin has to see some of your
movies the what Charlie Chaplin asked to
see some of your films you were telling
us at lunch that was a very good story
which one was it that he has to have a
print of well I asked him for a print of
modern time when I got home from my
two-week stay with him at his own it was
waiting in the hallway of my home with a
large Ted to my friend Jerry
good luck love your friend Charlie and I
got that print I've never put it on a
projector will you not if I want to
protect it then he writes me thank you
for the trip and thanks for all of the
kind words but if you got a print from
me I want one from you
I want the bellboy and I want a mint
condition because he had said he had
sent me a mint condition of modern times
you want to buy it how much nobody's got
enough yeah